if someone has actually never seen
anything you've done before what would
you like them to watch first and why I
would like them to watch
um it's a very interesting question
I'd like them to watch a short
um
a short movie that I did a fresh out of
acting school
it's a bit it's a bit dark it's about uh
I'm portraying like kind of a
weird Twisted character
[Music]
um
but it's it's it's one of the
performance I'm most uh proud about or I
felt more authentic about and
I don't know if it's easy to find but I
I feel like this would be
the the performance that characterize
characterizes or yeah you're close
you feel free to you know I'm still
doing this in a foreign language so sure
characterizes yeah it's yeah my my my
drive and my passion for this craft I
definitely have to ask you what is the
secret to playing uh the love interest
of Julia Roberts uh profound love and
admiration for Julia it's it's it's as
simple as this you know and then you go
with the flow I can't imagine uh what
it's like to tell your friends and
family by the way I booked a movie it's
gonna have Julia Roberts oh yes it also
has George Clooney in it
actually it's it's true you know when I
when I would announce it to it took me a
while to announce it to my family and
friends I wanted to work first and and
not get distracted
but when I did I I always it was fun
because I wasn't I was halfway through
announcing it just with one name and
they were already so happy I was like I
should keep the second name for later
just just to to keep like more length in
in this happy moment and uh it's yeah
it's it's too much almost yeah I'm I'm I
would imagine every project you make you
learn something about the craft how to
make it etc etc what did you actually
learn by watching Julia and George work
that you want to take with you to future
endeavors I learned that you can be an
icon and that you can be uh the biggest
actors on the planet and still be the
kindest person
and that for me
changes everything gives me a lot of
fuel you know there's a lot of ego in
this industry and to see that you can
make it this far and and and still keep
your inner child intact and and be a
respectful uh considerate person is for
me everything uh were you a little sad
that you didn't get to be involved in
the beer pong dancing stuff yes I I was
there I came to see the the scene that
night and
what you've seen the movie is actually
you know five percent of what happened
that night there's been a lot of dancing
a lot of different you know
um
Inspirations and nuances to George's
dance and I wish you guys could see all
of them because he went he went at it
and they left the stage drenched
completely wet from from from Leave it
all on the on the set
um is there and it might be this night
of filming but is there a day or two
that you will always remember from the
shoot
um you know like one of those just a
really memorable day
I I think the first day we had like this
plane in the in studio they recreated an
entire plane like an entire cabin and
this was pretty huge because I I arrived
and entered this little cabin and I was
in this little confined space with with
the biggest stars on the planet and uh
the contrasts about this little secluded
space and the energy they were
sending was was was kind of
weird to deal with and um so this is a
memory and the other one I guess would
be
um
I think the snake cave with Julia
because it was it was just a so
everything on paper was so weird you
know Australia summer Christmas
Julia Roberts snake poison me on the
front I was like what are the choices
that brought me to this moment it's a
good scene though yeah on that note I
gotta stop I'm just going to say
seriously congrats I wish you nothing
but the best thank you man thank you for
your time